comme il semble difficile pour les
journalistes d'obtenir un moment de
vérité de sincérité lors d'une interview
politique et pourtant pour y parvenir
les formules n'ont pas manqué c'est ce
que vient de nous démontrer à l'instant
ce documentaire réalisé par Nicolas
maupier et écrit par Nathalie Kuman
pourquoi une telle difficulté et bien
nous allons nous poser la question
maintenant dans ce débat doc avec mes
invités en commençant par vous Nathalie
Saric bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
éditorialiste politique sur France
télévision vous avez notamment coanimé
c'était en 2017 le débat télévisé
d'entre de tour de la présidentielle
opposant Emmanuel Macron à Marine Le Pen
votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule l'ombre
d'un traître publié aux éditions
humnensis c'est l'histoire c'est roman
policier inspiré d'ailleurs d'une
histoire vraie dans les années 60 où des
anciens combattants de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale ont été choisis par De Gaulle
pour faire leur entrer dans la crypte du
montvalérien formidable roman je le
conseille et c'est à découvrir aux
éditions humain 6 Roseline bachelou est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
bien entendu vous avez été à nombreuses
reprises ministres vous avez même eu
cinq portefeuilles ministériels votre
dernier portefeuille sous le quinquena
précédent était celui de la culture
entre juillet 2020 et mai 2022 et vous
en avez tiré un livre qui s'intitule 682
jours c'est le le chiffre exact le
nombre de jours exacts que vous avez
passé à la tête de ce ministère la
culture et il est publié chez plomb chez
plomb Jean-Luc Manot est également avec
nous bienvenue Jean-Luc Manot vous êtes
ancien journaliste ancien directeur
notamment de l'information à France 2
vous êtes aujourd'hui conseiller en
communication notamment hein notamment
auprès de personnalités politiques que
vous coachez entre autres entre autres
aussi pour cet exercice si particulier
de l'interview politique Nathalie sacric
à la vue de ce documentaire c'est c'est
vrai que je me suis dit que c'était
peut-être le monde un peu à l'envers
puisque c'est souvent l'interview qui se
retrouverait en position de force par
rapport à l'interviewer et j'ai noté
quelques phrases prononcées par des
confrères qui ne figurent pas dans le
film que nous venons de voir Sonia
bambrook notamment qui officie
aujourd'hui sur ces news et europin mais
qui a été à bonne école he puisqu'elle a
été formée par Jean-Pierre el Cabache je
la cite c'est très dur de faire basculer
les politiques dans un discours horors
cadre sincèrement 90 % de ce que je fais
ne sert à rien je me bats pour les 10 %
qui restent quant à Jean-Pierre el
cabach qui était lui considéré commeme
une des références de son vivant de
exercice de l'interview politique il
disait nous journalistes nous sommes pas
en état de force pour lancer des sujets
ce sont les politiques qui les lance et
nous aboyons autour de l'os en les
faisant réagir moi compris disait-il
nous sommes souvent des perroquets
est-ce que nous en sommes là concernant
le travail des journalistes sur ces
fameuses interviews politiques je ne
crois pas je ne crois pas d'abord parce
que ça dépend des personnalités qu'on
interview et ça dépend des journalistes
qui interviewent concernant les
personnalités si vous avez quelqu'un qui
ment comme un arracheur de dents ou qui
assène de fausses valeurs et qui en gros
vous vous entraînnez dans un débat on
est effectivement en position de
faiblesse puisque normalement et on a vu
ça souvent avec Jean-Marie Le Pen
c'estàd que les journalistes arrivai
pour se le payer lui disait ce qu'
voulait et on pouvait toujours courir
derrière et ça donnait l'impression
désagréable c'était un débat et non pas
une interview alors alors que on le voit
aussi dans le documentaire quand Albert
duoi essaie de poser clairement de
petites questions pas de rentrer dans un
débat il obtient des choses il est
également difficile par exemple
d'interviewer Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon soit vous
invective soit vous met en en position
difficile parce que il ne répond pas aux
questions il fait un débat politique
Nicolas Sarkozi aussi parfois difficile
parce que lui en gros sa techtique
c'était de déstabiliser dès le début
c'est de vous coincer genre on vous pose
une question sur le taux d'ortation du
charbon en 1912 évidemment vous savez
pas même si vous avez préparé et là il
se mettait en position de force mais je
pense que en fonction de la quantité de
travail qu'on fournit avant de l'analyse
les questions faut les réécrire 25 fois
et puis faut pas les faire pour faire un
numéro soi-même faut les faire en se
disant regarde moi quand je le faisais
je regardais toutes les interviews
jusqu'à la veille et je me disais bon
elle a déjà répondu là-dessus comment
est-ce que je peux essayer non pas de le
coincer mais de faire progresser alors
évidemment il y a beaucoup de bla comme
tout le regenberg mais il y a quand même
des moments où quand l'homme politique
est honnête sincère et qui joue le jeu
un peu à l'anglo-saxon où on a des
réponses donc des hommes politiques des
femmes politiques qui jouent le jeu pour
reprendre la
Form AZ en tête là qui n'arrive pas pour
bah oui alors le problème de ce que j'ai
en tête c'est plutôt du passé si vous
voulez donc je pas donner dans le
c'était mieux avant mais c'est vrai
qu'on pouvait interviewer pasqu c'est
vrai qu'on a pu même Sarkozi c'était
possible
c'est Léa Salamé dans ce documentaire
dit on avait AFF faaire avant des bêtes
politiqueselle dire aujourhui on na pas
ce personnel ce personnel politique là
interview a raison bah elle a raison
partie quand on voit George marcher
interviewer il avait du talent de toute
façon même s'il ne répondait pas à la
question c'était du spectacle donc dans
tous les cas ce n'était pas ennuyeux
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le le côté
d'abord ils sont partout il y a des
interview politiques la multiplication
des interview politiques fait qu'au bout
d'un moment c'est complètement B disit
parce qu'on a entendu Olivier verr 54
fois dans la semaine sur tous les je
parle de lui mais je pourrais parler
très bien de Deric siti ou de n'importe
qui d'autre manuel bonpa et que au bout
d'un moment c'est tellement ce qu'ils
vont dire parce que c'est tellement rodé
que franchement c'est effectivement ils
sont en position de force mais c'est
probablement à cause de la
multiplication des des des interviews
politiques et puis parce que ils sont
attendus et puis qu'il répètent toujours
la même chose et qui font attention à
tout donc effectivement peut-être que la
formation qu'on leur prodigue Mo onand
Rosine Bachelot est-ce que c'est un
exercice que vous avez craint cette
interview
politique ou alors est-ce que ça dépend
de la personnalité de l'intervieweur
pour rebondir ce que je viens de dire
sur Nathalie
SRC j'ai eu le sentiment regardant le le
le documentaire que vraiment il y avait
un moment presque historique et que ce
qui est mis dans le documentaire je ne
l'ai pas du tout ressenti dans mes
dernières années de vie politique il y a
eu des formation tout à fait
considérable vousz pas répondu à ma
question ça vous a fait
peur mais en tout cas il y a une
constante c'est que le stress de
l'interview politique est vraiment
maximum c'est quelque chose de de de
très de très dur à encaisser le risque
que prennent les hommes et les femmes
politiques dans une interview est tout à
fait considérable on sait que le fact
checking pour parler en bon français va
être incroyable et que la moindre erreur
vous aurez pu vous déployer avec
intelligence avec pertinence pendant une
demi-heure vous dites un chiffre faux
qui fusille complètement votre
parole ça c'est extrêmement dur et ça ça
ça a augmenté au fur et à mesure de mes
40 années de vie politique le fact
cheaking il a il y a 25 ans n'existait
quasiment pas maintenant il est il est
classique il est systématique mais c'est
très bien c'est pas une critique que je
fait et ensuite tout est tout est
décortiqué votre votre habillement votre
façon de parler votre coiffure surtout
pour les femmes bien entendu euh et et
là c'est c'est le stress maximum
particulièrement sur l'entretien du
matin ouais donc on est plutôt en radio
ou ça pe en télé on plutôt on est plutôt
en radio mais c'est sur les chaînes
d'info il y a aussi de toute façon tout
est filmé même en radio aujourd'hui mon
que les
mais vous avez pas de coiffeur pas de
maquilleur et vous arrivez dans une
chaîne de radio le matin il y a 25 ans
vous y venir en pyjama maintenant vous
êtes obligé d'être
lustré est
plusile pu y a l'actualité qui s'est
déroulé pendant la nuit il y a le fait
que vos conseillers les gens qui peuvent
éventuellement vous épauler sont là ou
pas là vous êtes plus ou moins en forme
l'entretien du matin qui est devenu un
classique aussi bien sur les chaînes de
radio que sur les chaînes de télévision
c'est un stress maximum moi j'ai eu peur
mais j'ai eu peur à tous les entretiens
à toutes les interviews j'ai eu le
sentiment d'être au bout de ma vie à
chacune de ces interviews quand on me
dit c'est ce sont les hommes et les
femmes politiques qui tiennent la chose
alors là je pardon vous êtes jamais mis
dans la peau d'un homme ou d'une femme
politique élément de langage ça ça a été
prononcé plusieurs fois dans ce film euh
et c'est ce sont ces fameuxes élément de
langage
euh B que vous transmettez probablement
un certain nombre de de personnalités
politiques qui sont passer entre vos
mains hein si je peux dire les choses
comme ça euh est-ce que finalement vous
avez pas trop bien réussi finalement
votre votre métier hein de consultants
de conseillers pour en arriver au
constat qui est fait comme par pas mal
de confrères quand même d'abord comme ça
vient d'être dit il y a des différentes
sortes d'hommes politiques femmes
politiqu différentes sortes de
journalistes il y a peut-être
accepterz-le l'idée qu' est différentes
sortes de conseiller moi je je je moi
j'ai une règle c'est de dire si vous
n'avez rien à dire n'y allez pas ce qui
entre nous soit dit est une précaution
utile euh la deuxième chose c'est euh
allez-y en disant ce que vous pensez
sinon ça n'a pas de ça n'a pas d'intérêt
ça n'a pas de vérité Yv murouszi qui m'a
formé en partie disait la télévision ça
transpire c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment
donné on on on on voit les choses et
vous ne pouvez pas mentir indéfiniment
tout le temps surtout et et et à tout le
monde donc c'est une épreuve de vérité
aussi une interview pour bon les
éléments de pour la personne qui va les
éléments de langage c'est une réflexion
préalable de travail en imaginant les
questions qui vont être posées B
forcément d'ailleurs besoin avec
beaucoup de journalistes d'être
formidablement imaginatif a priori elles
sont dans l'actualité et puis de tester
les les les les réponses d'essayer
d'aller jusqu'au bout de de la de la
production de sens si on peut on peut
l'espérer je vais être honnête de temps
en temps il y a des moments il y a des
des lignes de fuite parce que vous avez
deux types d'interview vous avez
l'interview vous allez volontiers parce
que vous avez quelque chose à dire et
puis vous avez l'interview vous allez
contre forcer j'avais envie de dire à
l'insut de votre pleiné ou surtout
lorsqu'on est porte-parole d'une
formation Politi porte-parole du
gouvernement faut faut y aller
pour principal de l'interview politique
c'est l'ennui c'est l'ennui donc moi je
me bats avec les les gens avec que je
conseille pour éviter l'ennui parce que
soyons honnête vous avez allez vous avez
80 % 70 allez j'enlève le le chiffre
vous avez un pourcentage assez important
de politique qui ne disent rien dans les
interviews rigoureusement rien
nietevo nada et donc là vous êtes dans
une situation moi j'étais quand je vous
avais dit tout à l'heure directeur de
l'information France 2 enfin écoutez il
y avait un moment donné je vais pas
donner de nom mais on en faisait venir
un paquet parce qu'il y avait l'égalité
des temps de parole et qu'il fallait
bien pas se faire engueuler par le CSA
et qu' fallait les appeler et on était
là on trépignit on disait mais tu vas
finir par dire quelque chose oui ou non
et en général c'était non non mais je je
je on a travaillé ensemble je confirme
d'abord il y a effectivement une je
comprends aussi ce que peut dire
Roseline même si les journalistes
peuvent avoir peur de certains
politiques qui sont tordus qui qui
essaie tout de suite prendre l'ascendant
quand je vous parle des questions en
disant mais alors hein le PIB vous avez
dans ce cas-là c'est on a travailler sur
le PIB l'agriculture n'importe quoi on
est on a une chance sur de de se faire
de se faire avoir il y a certains
journalistes qui veulent faire trèbûer
les politiques moi je considère que
quand on est journaliste on n'est pas là
pour faire trébucher on est là pour
poser des questions mais il est évident
qu'ils sont pas omniscients et à coup de
porte-avion nucléaire je trouve que
c'était un peu la méthode Bourdin si
vous voulez régulièrement alors
peut-être avait-il raison en
prour absument mais qui en gros les en
période présidentielle on savait qu'il
allait essayer de vous
coller donc si vous voulez c'est une
méthode que je trouve
c'est pas un signe d'indépendance c'est
pas un signe de qualité je trouve de
d'essayer de se les payer voilà non pas
par conivance simplement les faire
préciser ça je trouve que c'est plus
intéressant et pour revenir sur les
éléments de langage quand on est entre
des ministres ou des gens de
l'opposition qui ont des choses qu'ils
ne veulent pas dire ou qu'ils ne doivent
pas dire c'est-à-dire je fais ça d'un
point de vue politique parce que si
j'accepte la loi immigration telle
qu'elle est je vais pas être un bon
opposant donc si je suis un mauvais
opposant je ne pourrais pas gagner en
2027 je sais pas à qui vous pouvez
penser mais moi j'ai une idée où est-ce
plus ceux qui veulent nous fourguer pour
parler vulgairement un message c'est
vrai qu'il y a des moments on se dit
c'est pas possible ou ce alors autre
style qui ont pose une question et qui
commencent àir mais je vais d'abord vous
dire quelque chose et là on se tape un
propos liminire qu'ils essaient de faire
le plus long possible où en gros ils
viennent dire ce qu'ils ont l'intention
de dire et où ça n'a aucun rapport avec
la question donc je pense que au bout
d'un moment effectivement ça peut
devenir épuisant et accessoirement je
pense et ça jeanluc n'est peut-être pas
d'accord avec moi que les gens qui ont
quelque chose à dire que ça plaise ou
pas je trouve que ceuxl ont une côte
forcément un petit peu plus intéressante
je préférerais et j'ai nous on a fait
des études inv vivo c'est-à-dire avec
des gens qui regardaient une émission
même si vous êtes pas d'accord avec la
personne qui dit ça si la personne a des
convictions en disant écoutez ça va pas
vous plaire mais moi je vous dis que ça
ça et ça il a
aussiie le format de l'émission qui a
beaucoup changé moi ce qui m'a frappé
dans ce document excellent d'ailleurs
c'est que il y a beaucoup d'entretiens
en tête à-tête et que là maintenant
l'homme ou la femme politique est
exposée dans un entretien en fait ce ne
sont plus des entretiens on rentre sur
le ring en totale inégalité on va vous
coller un spécialiste qui va vous parler
de telle chose il y en a trois ou quatre
on va vous mettre face à un panel
d'électeurs c'est un exercice absolument
épouvantable parce que comme disait mon
mon brave
père tu ne seras jamais emmerdé par une
question intelligente mais tu vas foirer
sur une connerie pardon pour la
vulgarité d'expression mais c'est
exactement ce qui est en train de se
passer euh dans dans un certain nombre
dans un certain nombre d'interview on a
aussi et ce qui devient terrible mais
Nathalie connaît bien ça c'est
l'interview à deux c'est-à-dire avec des
types qui n'ont qu'une idée c'est de se
contrebalancer les uns les autres ils
font pas un débat avec la personne
politique il faut un débat entre eux
pour se prendre le maximum de temps de
parole et vous avez l'impression
d'assister à un espèce de match
impossible entre des journalistes il y a
peut-être un effet aussi de la de la
d'une certaine baisse de la qualité du
personnel politique et qui qui laisse
plus de place aux journalistes qui ont
plus envie de se stariser quand vous
étiez vous vouliez est le meilleur
journaliste du Monde formidable très
connu vous étiez face à de Gaulle vous
étiez face à miterran il y avait il y
avait pas photo malgré tout bon là quand
vous êtes face au trème couteau n
j'allais pas le faire au 3ème couteau de
du du 4e parti forcément vous avez une
place qui est qui est supplémentaire et
d'ailleurs parfois les gens viennent
regarder plutôt le journaliste ou la
journaliste que que que que l'interview
ils viennent à la matinale 2 parce
qu'ils aiment bien le le le le le
journaliste donc il y a aussi
alie
suspectait a un instant de préférer les
gens qu' rien à dire mais mais mais mais
en l'occurrence non je pense que pour
aller à la télévision il faut avoir
quelque chose à dire et c'est le rôle du
journaliste de faire produire du sens et
des idées alors le quelque chose à dire
c'est la reprise c'est la petite phrase
alors on pas beaucoup entendu
parler non non mais quelque chose à dire
ça peut être aussi la fameuse punchline
ça pe la petite phrase et d'abord les
rédactions attendent la petite phrase
d'une interview politique parce que elle
va être relayée par les agences de
presse aujourd'hui par les réseaux
sociaux on en parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure est-ce que vous aviez des
punchlines prévu quelques qui soit pas
forcément des informations mais des
choses dont vousz sûr qu'elle qu'
qu'elles infuseraient qu'elles seraient
reprises par la suite
non moi ce qui comptait c'est est-ce
qu'on a une annonce à faire ouis est-ce
qu'on a quelque chose de nouveau à dire
donc là vous rejoignez ce c'est ça et je
ne me suis jamais déplacé dans une
interview en me disant qu'est-ce que je
vais apporter à l'information la
punchline les terres son de sable ù
s'efface le pas des vainqueurs mais si
vous avez une annonce vous allez être
prise puis vous apportez quelque chose
au débat public Jean-Luc mano juste une
question l'école anglo-saxon de
l'interview politique est-ce qu'elle est
meilleure que l'école française l'école
anglo-saxone on est plus factuel on ne
mélange pas le commentaire et et le
factuel he c'est un peu ça et nous on
nous reproche à l'inverse parfois dans
notre profession en France de mélanger
un petit peu les deux est-ce que l'école
anglo-saxonne fait mieux en matière
d'interview politique que nous Français
non je dirais pas qu'elle fait mieux
c'est un genre différent d'abord c'est
un genre qu'ils ont inventé ça c'est la
première chose malgré tout la deuxième
chose c'est que il y a historiquement
moins de
consanguinité entre le monde politique
et le monde des journalistes un des
problèmes du monde journalistique
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas la faute des
journalistes c'est que c'est les mêmes
que les politiques même origine sociale
la plupart du temps même même résidence
en métropole
de la même mêmes habitudes souvent même
niveau culturel Johson vient vous
contredire là même niveau culturel moi
je parle en France en France chez nous
chez nous chez nous c'est moins c'est
bien moins le cas c'est plus diversifié
dans les milieux en milieu anglo-saxon
bon il y a une école qui est une école
moins d'tanchéité c'est vous vlez nous
dire voilà il y a une école qui est plus
qui qui qui est effectivement plus rude
dans dans dans dans l'interview et et et
qui est pas adaptable parce que quand je
vois il y a rien de pire que immitation
mauvaise en plus quelques journalistes
français qui dans les interviews disent
on va essayer de faire comme nos
confrères américain vous savez il y a
une jolie formule je crois qu'ellere
Victor Hugo quand le quand le lion imite
le singe à la fin il devient le singe
bon bah c'est pas c'est pas voilà ça ne
ça ne fonctionne pas dans notre dans
notre dans notre logique ni dans notre
culture alors on va regarder un extrait
du documentaire Nathalie c'est un truc à
deux c'estàd que les les politiques
anglais ont un peu plus de respect pour
les journalistes donc si vous voulez ah
oui mais attendez ce que si on considère
que les journalistes français sont un
petit peu mou ou connivant ou qu'on
sengage j'en sais rien c'est aussi parce
que pendant toute une période si vous
vous teniez mal en posant des questions
vous étiez punis par les politiques si
vous aviez pas un directeur de l'info ou
quelqu'un qui vous couvrait ou un
président
euh donc c'est aussi le les les
politiques qui ne respectent pas les
journalistes après vous allez me dire
c'est peut-être parce qu'ils sont pas
respectables mais enfin on est tous payé
pour savoir qu'il y a des gens qui ont
posé des questions qu' ne fallait pas
comme on voit Chabot dans le
documentaire qu qui pose la question à
Chirac du gens vous avez pas envisagé
d'abandonner elle a été punie elle a été
punie après sanctionné hein mais il y a
des il y a des politiques qui rêvent
d'un univers sans journaliste ça existe
pensait qu'il serait plus tranquille
alors je vous l'avez promis premier
extrait du documentaire hardardisson
Rocard mythique est-ce que euh embrasser
c'est trompé oh non ah bon qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette philosophie que vous
nous trimbalez là je sais pas je vous
demande moi mais ça dépend du contexte
et j'espère bien que non ah ouais
ouais et suc c'est trompé et pardon suc
c'est trompé non plus non
plus c'est sûr que un journaliste
politique lambda je dire même moi
j'irais jamais demander un homme
politique si suc s trompé il faut avoir
la liberté d'une certaine manière d'un
d'un animateur qui n'est pas journaliste
pour oser regarder Michel Rocard en lui
demandant su s'est trompé Salamé
n'aurait pas osé on touche le caniveau
avec cette interview ce entre hordisson
et et Rocard étant donné les liens qui
me li à Michel Rocard et qui
philosophiquement me lit toujours je
dois dire que je suis très mal à l'aise
devant cette interview je mais on on
voit aussi le stress sur un plateau d'un
homme politique qui tout d'un coup est
comme piégé et qui croit que pour rester
dans l'ambiance de cette de cette
interview est obligé d'aller avec le le
l'intervieweur le journaliste
l'animateur Paron peut à peine parler de
journaliste là et a écoutez je ne
réponds pas à ce genre de question on
refuse
toute toute question sur la vie
personnel sur ses habitudes affectives
ou sexuelles faut absolument les refuser
ça ça soulève une autre question hein
faut-il qu'un journaliste soit qualifié
pour intervener un responsable politique
parce que là on est de dans ce on
appelle l'info term c'estàd à de
l'information et euh et de la détente
oui pardon vasy oui non mais c'est mieux
évidemment la question est-ce que c'est
mieux de d'être d'avoir travaillé
d'avoir du métier être intelligent la
réponse est trois fois trois fois oui et
trois fois oui mais mais si vous voulez
là le le l'extrait que vous V passé
c'est c'est c'est insupportable en
réalité c'est l'idée que ce qui va être
bien c'est c'est d'avoir un mormon à la
Las Vegas c'est-à-dire d'être dans une
espèce de de de de choc complètement de
de de culture ça n'a rien de ça n'a rien
d' ça n'a rigoureusement rien
d'intéressant et moi je dis à un certain
nombre de mes clients je leur
déconseille je leur demande de ne pas
aller dans un certain nombre d'émissions
il y a un certain nombre d'émissions qui
de mon point de vue ne sont pas
fréquentables elles ne sont pas
fréquentables non pas pour des raisons
idéologique mais elles ne sont pas
fréquentables parce que on n'est pas
dans l'éthique normale du question
et quand même les médias ça sert à
servir la
démocratie mais le fait est qu'on a vu
beaucoup de confrères journalistes aller
dans des informations des émissions on
va dire de divertissement ou
d'infoertainment et à l'inverse on a vu
beaucoup de politique aller aussi sur
Cees mêmes plateau d'abord on n pas nous
n'avons pas de mépris pour les
animateurs les animateurs ont le droit
de faire ce qu'ils veulent simplement
c'est des animateurs animateurs ça doit
animer ça doit être drôle ça doit faire
des événements quand on regarde un truc
le samedi soir on n' pas envie d'avoir
quelque chose sur la la baisse de taux
d'intérêt et savoir si le taux de la
Banque de France va bon très bien donc
ça n'est pas de la supériorité de notre
part du genre on est les sachants on est
plus intelligent mais à côté de ça
imaginez alors je sais que ça va être le
poid godoun que vous ayez une émission
pareil en 1933 ou je sais pas quoi qu'on
vous aieez eu un jour gobels à qui on
demande de faire ça je pense que c'est
un peu problématique donc que les
politiques aillent dans ce genre
d'émission je trouve ça navrant mais il
faut se souvenir qu'à l'époque d'abord
beaucoup d'hommes politiques confond
la notoriété et la popularité
c'est-à-dire avec ce genre d'émission il
pouvait acquérir une forme de notoriété
ça reconnu dans la rue au marché ce qui
ne voulait pas dire pour autant que les
Français respectai ce genre de chos et
honnêtement ils ont tous dit au début on
nira pas et après ils sont tous allés
parce qu'ils cherchaient à être aimé et
qui ne savaient pas par quel bout
prendre le problème je suis pas contre
le fait d'aller dans une émission de de
d'infotainment et je suis allé dans jus
certain point jusqu'à certain point
c'est ça mais c'est à un moment c'est
vous qui choisissez de répond vous
demander ce que vous aimez lire on peut
faire chanter de l'Opéra puisque vous
aimz l'OP moment pas l'impression de
perdre ma dignité mais attendez attendez
parce que là tout à l'heure vous nous
disiez moi j'ai stressé oui pour les
interview politiques et à chaque
interview politique quand vous allez sur
ce type de plateau on stresse moins
quand on est responsable politique on
stresse de la même façon parce que
justement le danger est beaucoup plus
grand et on est encore plus sur ses
gardes parce qu'on sait que à tout
moment ça peut déraper donc ça se
prépare parce qu'il faut toujours tout
préparer et euh voilà le stress est
est-ce que vous êtes livré dans
l'intimité dans votre intimité auprès
d'un euh d'un journaliste Karine
Lemarchand avait tenté cet exercice
c'est vrai à l'occasion d'une émission
présidentielle en recevant chacun des
candidats et et en essayant d'aller
chercher un peu d'intimité on l'a vu
hein dans dans ce film est-ce que
vous-même vous êtes livré un petit peu à
cet exercice qui consiste à à livrer un
peu de son intimité tout dépend à quel
moment on met la frontière de l'intime
mais j'ai fait par exemple l'émission de
Frédéric Lopez ouais qui est une
émission où sans c'est c'est pas
voyuriste mais on échange sur des
souvenirs d'enfance et j'ai jamais eu
l'impression d'être d'être mal àaise
avec ce journaliste et ça an pere
apporter quelque chose à V carère peut
apporter quelque chose de de la
connaissance de savoir pourquoi
finalement il faut qu'il y ait un fil
conducteur c'est-à-dire que votre propos
explique pourquoi vous êtes dans la
politique qu'est-ce qui vous a amené
dans ce cheminement pourquoi finalement
vous avez pris tel ou telle orientation
et ça apporte quelque chose mais c'est
pas neutre de savoir d'où on parle et où
on parle quand même c'est pas que du
décor c'est aussi une manière le cadre
lescrain de la vie démocratique et de la
vie politique et de ce point de vue
globalement les politiques et un certain
nombre de directions de médias baisser
la garde on accepé on dit que tout était
dans tout et réciproquement et moi moi
que que que qu'un responsable politique
est dans une émission de divertissement
je trouve ça très bien qu'on aille même
faire dans des émissions intimes
pourquoi pas s'il en a envie et pourquoi
pas et je suis aussi curieux et je les
regarde et et je les écoute mais je veux
pas qu'on me vende une émission de
divertissement comme une émission
politique c'est pas la même c'est pas la
même chose et et et et ça c'est une
vraie question et ça amène espèce de de
dérive qui fait que n'importe quel
animateur euh peut s'ériger en
éditorialiste politique ou en
interviewur politique et que de l'autre
côté des journalistes se sonent obligés
dans leur travail de journaliste de
devenir animateur donc au bout d'un
moment il y a besoin un peu de de de
repère de savoir où on habite c'est
assez important quand même dans un pays
endez on parlait juste de cette question
l'idée de demander à une femme ou un
homme politique s'il croit en Dieu ce
que ses parents lu on
si il pens qu'aujourd'hui on devrait
avoir on a quand on a nous on voulait
avoir des enfants mais peut-être la
génération actuelle ne veut plus en
c'est très intéressant c'est dis très
mais su s trompé je ne vois même pas ce
que ça apporte si ce n'est faire un truc
dire comme les momes qui disent une
grossierté pour voir la tête de leurs
parents voilà c'est tout non parce que
cette réponse l'entraîne pas un vote
favorable ou négatif de la part de
l'opinion a priori enfin il y a peu de G
il y a peu de gens qui se déterminent
là-dessus enfin alors on connait pas les
mêmes gens roselou on va passer deè
extrait sera le dernier d'ailleurs
Patrick Cohen d'une part et Carl zé
d'autre part nous parlent des médias
sociaux l'explosion de à la fois des
réseaux sociaux et des chaînes de télé à
à produit c'est la multiplication du
nombre de de gens qui font cet exercice
d'intervieweur si j'avais 20 ans
aujourd'hui je serais sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur internet je serai là où
ça se passe là où cette génération là
peut s'exprimer alors cette génération
là dans le film que nous nous avons vu
ensemble euh elle elle est symbolisée
par Hugo traver hein qui se fait aussi
appeler Hugo décrypte je citer quelques
chiffres concernant ses ses abonnés ses
followers YouTube 2,35 millions
d'abonnés un titre de comparaison
uniquement pour YouTube hein LCI compte
aujourd'hui
1, 14 millions d'abonnés euh France Info
526000 abonnés euh ça a apporté quelque
chose de nouveau euh les youtubeurs qui
eux aussi se prête à l'exercice de
l'interview politique Carl zer dit moi
si fallait que j'y aille j'irais vers ça
ça qu'est-ce que ça apportte ça comment
on fait les choses Hugo traver il a 26
ans aujourd'hui oui bah al avoir 26 ans
c'est pas un signe d'intelligence mais
c'est intéressant d'avoir des gens de 26
ans parce qu' d'abord il représente une
grande partie de la population qui ne
vote pas énormément donc que les jeunes
parlent aux jeunes c'est très bieni le
le c'est le vecteur n'est pas en soi un
problème puisque on peut utiliser tous
les vecteurs en fonction des gens à qui
on veut pas parler je sais que les gens
ne regardent plus les jeunes ne
regardent
plus le vinur ou regarde une
consommation de médias qui est pioché à
droite et et à gauche donc c'est très
bien mais si j'ose dire car zé dit si
j'étais aujourd'hui je Seris sur les
réseaux sociaux moi ce qui me gênait
chez Carl zé c'est sa façon
d'interviewer donc qu'il le fasse à la
télé il y a 20 ans ou qu'il le fasse sur
les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est c'est le
principe si il y a un jeune youtubeur
qui raconte n'importe quoi s'il fait
l'influenceur en clair si fait le
journaliste ou s'il pose des bonnes
questions si fait de la pédagogie en
expliquant aux gens c'est plus compliqué
quand on dit quand on quand on trouve
tel solution voilà qui explique
l'histoire d'Israël aujourd'hui pour pas
qu'on qu'on décrète n'importe quoi parce
qu'on connaît rien à l'histoire après
toute façon c'est l'évolution naturelle
et il faut
l'accepter et c'est très bien que les
gens puissent piocher là où ils veulent
vous êtes prêté à cet exercice soit sur
une chaîne Youtube soit sur twitch hein
aujourd'hui
he
ma carrièreque qu'est-ce que ça a changé
dans dans alors c'est pas tellement
la mais c'est plutôt la forme la forme
habit enfin la forme qu'on promut d'une
fausse familiarité et ça ça m'a beaucoup
gêné dans cet exercice le tutoiement
alors comment tu
vas je pense que ça fausse le
l'expression politique parce que l'homme
politique pense ou la femme politique
pense que il faut se mettre dans ce jeu
qui n'est pas le sien et qui est
finalement à chaque fois ce qui m'a gêné
de toute façon globalement c'est
l'inauthenticité le fait de jouer un
personnage qui n'est pas le vôtre dans
la communication parce que à partir du
moment où on a on on adopte des codes
qui ne sont pas les vôtres forcément on
se met à mentir dans le message et et
c'est et c'est ça qui m'a gêné dans ces
dans ces nouveaux médias mais sans doute
parce que je suis une vieille dame qui
n'est pas habituée à ça comme D car zo
si j'avais 50 ans de moins ça me
gênerait pe-être moi non moi je suis
assez pragmatique là-dessus je veux dire
si cette présence là ce ce ces nouveaux
ces nouveaux usages permettent aux 76 %
des 18 24 ans qui ne sont pas allés
voter au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de s'intéresser à la vie
publique de s'intéresser à la vie de
leur pays je trouve qu'à l'arrivée c'est
quand même plutôt positif sans jamais
oublier que c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose ça que les réseaux sociaux
parce que les réseaux sociaux c'est
aussi assez souvent un immonde cloaque
quand vous regardez ce qui se dit
aujourd'hui sur l'antisémitisme en
France c'est un cloaque il se dit des
choses absolument ignobles et avec une
une loi un pouvoir qui est démuni sur
ces choses qu'il faudrait interdire ne
ne ne ne ne pas tolérer donc euh c'est
en en réalité c'est pas le c'est pas le
support qui est important c'est ce qui
se dit et comment est traité le le le le
le le support et un antisémite sur un un
réseau social c'est pas mieux ou pire
qu'un antisémite à la télévision il y en
a des deux côtés il faut ajouter qu'il y
a une opacité dans le financement de ces
médias alors que les médias qu'il soient
classiques qui soient publ ou privé faut
faut toujours savoir d'où on parle à la
fin qui paye pardon mais c'est très très
important accessoirement quand on voit
les questions faitstra donc vous êtes en
train de nous dire qu'il en va de la
crédibilité bien entendu de l'interview
qui peut être diffusé sur ces fameux
dire c'est qu'on pr on prait à plat les
questions posées par Hugo ou par des
gens sur brut et tout ça qu'on les
regardit elles sont pas très très
différent des des des journalistes juste
quand tu tu dit arrête là ça te fait ça
fait impertinent mais c'est pas tour les
mêmes ça sera le mot de la fin grand
merci vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc aujourd'hui euh
pour parler ensemble de cet exercice si
particulier hein qu l'interview
politique auprès euh d'un responsable
politique justement vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtagdbadoc euh merci à Alice
de branon et euh Sarah eudoline euh de
m'avoir aidé à préparer cette émission
prochain rendez-vous avec des badoog ça
sera bien sûr même place même heure et
toujours avec son documentaire et son
débat à
bientôt
[Musique]